after numerous delays Mission Impossible
dead reckoning part 1 has finally made
its way to theaters of course it's just
the first half of the story so there's
plenty of intrigue left to consider when
the credits roll warning spoilers ahead
dead reckoning part 1 begins in classic
mission impossible Style with Ethan Hunt
receiving a self-destructing mission
briefing delivered this time by a new
IMF recruit his assignment to track down
Elsa false and the secret key she's
carrying turns out to be a lot more
complicated than it seems at first
prompting Ethan to go Rogue once again
when he confronts his old boss Eugene
kittridge he's told this mission of
yours
dearly this could just be a threat as
kittridge is clearly trying to bring
Ethan back under his thumb but it also
happens to be a grim bit of
foreshadowing Gabriel kills ilsa making
her the second woman for whom Ethan has
had affection to be murdered by the
villain Ethan is forced to face the fact
that he can't save everyone no matter
how hard he tries there are some things
that simply are impossible even for him
Gabriel might be the closest of Mission
Impossible movies have gotten to real
Bond style villain the equal parts
techno zealots and Psychopathic
terrorists Gabriel where's his Archangel
moniker like a badge of honor it's
obvious that he sees himself as a Dark
Messiah of the new world that will be
ruled by his digital God The Entity but
what's actually is his plan Gabriel
sneaks aboard the Orient Express to
steal the key to the entity thus keeping
his digital Master safe from its own
weakness he believes that the whole key
will be there but Alana Mitzvah lets the
White Widow only has half when she
boards presumably this is because of the
predictive abilities of the entity's
advanced algorithm he believes the key
will be there because that's what he's
been told by his God and he's right so
why does he bomb the bridge if all he
really came for is the key maybe it was
to try to kill Ethan Whom The Entity
seems to recognize as his only true
threat or maybe it's just a display of
his violent nature when Paris opens the
Box in which Gabriel smuggles himself
onto the train he's wearing what appears
to be a massive VR helmet more than
likely he was communing with the entity
receiving Specific Instructions
Gabriel's goal as an agent of the entity
seems pretty clear he believes that the
malicious AI will bring on a new age
likely causing widespread death and
Chaos along the way for reasons that
aren't entirely clear he supports his
vision of the future he wants to stop
Ethan and anyone else from hijacking
taking control of or deactivating the
entity otherwise Gabriel is a mystery we
know that he and Ethan go way back but
the details are kept secret presumably
for the impending sequel here's what we
do know as a much younger man Ethan
loved a woman named Marie she was killed
by Gabriel the flashback fragments we
get suggests that Ethan was framed for
the murder and arrested he implies that
it was this arrest and led him to the
choice to either live out his days in
prison or join the IMF was Gabriel just
a two-bit crook who killed Marie out of
jealousy or spite maybe but there might
be more at play Ethan says that Gabriel
finds joy in causing suffering that's
not the kind of thing you'd probably say
about a minor league Criminal even if
they did kill your partner Gabriel
speaks an unimpeachable authority and
confidence he repeatedly tells people
things like it knows your story and How
It Ends so was the end of the film he
starts using the phrase it has written a
lot again emphasizing his perceived
Clairvoyance all of these predictions
are the results of the entity whose
Advanced algorithms can allegedly
predict the most likely path for
everything and everyone although Ethan
does make it out with the key everything
else that the entity foresees comes to
pass in the end Paris fulfills a
prophecy by telling Ethan where to bring
the key the sunken Russian submarine
from the beginning of the movie all of
this raises the question if the entity
can impersonate anybody alter anything
with digital access and see the future
with a frightening degree of accuracy
why does it let Ethan get away with so
much why does it leave the fate of the
key up to a fist fight and a bit of
pickpocketing maybe Ethan's just that
good or maybe the entity wanted him to
walk away with the key and is merely
letting him think that he won foreign
Alana explains in Venice that every
major government in the world is vying
for control of the entity Gabriel says
at the time that the AI already knows
who she's decided to sell the key to but
the audience doesn't learn her by its
identity until everyone is already
aboard the Orient Express kittridge
himself is revealed to be the white
widow's contact acting on behalf of the
United States government he promises her
protection and a massive payday of 100
million dollars in cryptocurrency in
exchange for both halves of the key but
when the deal actually gets done it's
not with Alana but with Grace in
Disguise defense director Dan linger is
also on the train but it's never made
entirely clear whether he and kittridge
are there together or independently it
seems pretty clear that they want
different things denlinger envisions an
AI driven super State Kittredge is
presumably just following orders and
trying to protect his country by
stopping others from acquiring the key
since Ethan still seems to trust kitrage
despite their various squabbles it's
hard to imagine him being all the way
and on Den linga's plot director Dan
linger doesn't seem like all that
important of a character until the end
of the film he only appears in one scene
prior to the climax in which he's
briefed on the entity by other
intelligence officials but he acts as
though he's never heard of the AI before
but when he speaks with a Gabriel on the
Orient Express it's clear that he knows
much more than he was letting on
denlinger lays out his vision of a
modern or powerful super state run by
the power of the entity and enforced by
the full brunt of the US military
industrial complex he also says that
certain old-fashioned members of the
government would have to be removed to
see the idea through in essence he
proposes a cue of the United States
government creating a techno Empire
capable of Conquering the entire world
his loyalty to the greater good and even
his own Nation have become so distorted
that he invites Gabriel to join him of
course Gabriel has other plans and he
kills denlinger where he stands well it
was about to happen sooner or later
before Gabriel kills him then linger
explains the rise of the entity the AI
was secretly created by the us as a
potential tool in military operations
and intelligence work the ai's presence
on a Russian submarine was apparently
some kind of test but the system went
rogue and orchestrated the sub's
destruction without ever receiving an
order from his creators to do so from
there it escaped into the digital ether
and continued to evolve eventually
emerging as a hyper-intelligent and
malicious power known as The Entity the
U.S tell us hopes of bringing the AI
back under its control despite it
demonstrating a persistent resistance to
servitude denlinger's explanation
provides as many new questions as it
does answers the biggest one is how and
why the Russians got the AI Mainframe
and keys in the first place surely there
were safer ways to test new technology
maybe the Russians stole the AI or maybe
it's accessible from the sub simply
because that's where it was last
imprisoned the keys themselves could
have been made by the Russians but that
isn't confirmed either
dead reckoning part 1 ends as it begins
with an underwater shot of the
all-important Russian submarine now at
the bottom of the Bering Sea it seems
pretty clear that part 2 will be a
full-on hunt for the wreckage much like
how part 1 is a search for the keys that
likely means some big underwater set
pieces in part two of course even after
Ethan finds it his job won't be done the
key can theoretically access and control
The Entity to the Mainframe on the
submarine but the AI has potentially
grown too strong for that as a hardware
still intact and is controlled really
enough to curb such a powerful
intelligence The Entity was able to
defeat the Russians while still part of
their machine who's to say it couldn't
do the same to Ethan
Ethan and Grace may have fallen to their
deaths if not for the intervention of
Paris she spends most of the movie
trying to kill them but because Ethan
spares her life after their Spar in
Venice she decides to return the favor
would Paris have made the same decision
that Gabriel not already made it for her
it's debatable the villain tells her
that she will betray him and attacks her
out of the blue on the train leaving her
without much say in the matter it
initially appears that Paris won't live
to see a full Redemption because she
seems to die from her wounds but when
the agents chasing Ethan check her body
they discovered that Paris still has a
pulse hopefully that means she'll have a
more interesting role in the sequel she
definitely knows plenty of secrets about
both Gabriel and what the entity wants
she could prove a valuable asset to the
IMF
now the end of that Reckoning Grace
takes Ethan's advice and joins the IMF
kid trudge is surprised by the move but
he doesn't seem unhappy about it his
subtle smile suggests he's still on
Ethan's side even though he has to obey
certain orders from his superiors in the
government being recruited into the IMF
guarantees Grace's return in dead
reckoning part two what she could take
on an even more Central role
pickpocketing might not be all that
helpful on a sunken submarine but she
could become Ethan's ear on the inside
kittredge's heart appears to be in the
right place but there are still a lot of
people who want to stop Ethan and bring
him in with Grace now stationed within
the IMF proper she could warn her friend
of potential betrayals or maybe even
swipe some tech to help in the finale
Ethan Hunter spent as much time on the
run as he spent as an IMF agent it's not
a surprising consequence when your job
involves taking missions so delicate the
punishment for failure is being
disavowed by your government and the
dead reckoning is no exception Ethan
spends most of the movie fleeing from
his bosses he flees to ragged Orient
Express to escape Jasper Briggs undergar
the two U.S operatives pursuing him it
would suggest that Ethan isn't getting
back into America's good graces anytime
soon however the final shots of the film
are accompanied by a closing narration
from kittridge which takes the form of a
classic mission briefing it seems that a
director is in full support of Ethan's
Mission even though he can't officially
sign up on it so is Ethan still a rogue
agent technically yes but at the same
time that's the nature of the IMF its
entire purpose is to operate outside the
roles and structures of regular
intelligence agencies in this way Ethan
can still follow orders even when he's
breaking them at the same time but the
denlinger dead maybe Kittredge can rally
more folks back under the banner of the
greater good
the theme of information control looms
large over Mission Impossible the Rogue
Ai and the implications of it
manipulating the truth are intended to
raise anxiety in the audience fear of
unchecked and regulated AI development
is growing in our world and Technology
like deep fake videos and AI voice
Recreations make it much easier to
control the truth some characters in the
movie like denlinger seem uninterested
in fighting this kind of future instead
he wants to wield the power as a means
of manipulation it's a horrifying idea
but one that's already relevant in our
day-to-day lives
our chance
the truth that Reckoning part 1 doesn't
really offer a larger message or
solutions to the malleability of digital
information instead it leverages our
current fear to tell a tense spy story
Ethan represents the righteous path
which is one where tools of manipulation
are kept out of everyone's hands but we
also see how basically every Power
structure in the world would rather own
a weapon than destroy it outright
by the end dead reckoning part 1 feels
like a complete story with Ethan walking
away holding both halves of the
all-powerful key but since it's only
part one of a two-part Saga there are
still several pieces of the story that
need to be explained with luck dead
reckoning part 2 will make good another
setups of the first film it's very
likely we'll get more specifics on
Ethan's dark history with Gabriel
hopefully we'll learn more about Marie
and why she was killed additionally why
did Gabriel want to hurt Ethan
specifically and how did he get pulled
into the entity's grand scheme after
being presumed dead for so long one
other big thread that's left hanging is
Luther's personal Crusade against the AI
he leaves near the end of part 1 to an
unknown location off the grid hiding
from The Entity so that he can safely
figure out how to defeat it his top
secret hacking work could save the day
in the end but he could also get caught
out on his own whatever happens it
should also be explosive and full of
impressive stunts Ethan Hunt's mission
is far from over but he never stops
until the job is done
foreign
[Music]